you went to ucla
for a diagnosis
of your condition
that would normally be identified
via autopsy
this is freaky that's a freaky fact yeah
was it some new way to
make the measurement or did you just
sort of force
force it in on people and say look
something's going on
invent some new test because otherwise i
don't want you to do this after i'm dead
[Music]
this is star talk sports edition so i've
got chuck nice one of my co-hosts jack
what's up neil
all right all right every time i'm here
i have to list you as comedian and actor
and i haven't seen you acting anything
just look just between you and me
that's how great of an actor i am
no because you just played it
i don't even know it's you you don't
even know it's me
yeah okay you're like i thought that was
michael b jordan what
that was chuck nice okay all right maybe
that's it and of course gary o'reilly
gary former soccer pro in the uk so gary
you you felt compelled we could not
keep doing star talk sports edition
without hitting this topic so why don't
you give us the full intro that this
needs and requires so what's going on
today um right cte
or chronic traumatic encephalopathy is a
degenerative brain disease caused mainly
by repeated traumas to the head
now concussions are the most dramatic
of those but it could be from years of
heading a football it could be from
smaller contacts it could be from
contact sports like boxing or maybe
american football but when you said
heading of football you mean heading a
soccer ball yes because this is american
jack right
our footballs aren't round
[Laughter]
yes
if a ball hits a football player in the
head that's that's something wrong
happened in that play
all right so
if i say soccer i get pushback if i say
football i get pushed back i don't win
so that's true that's true you know it's
a square ball look the thing is cte is
not particularly well understood and up
until recently
diagnosis took place sadly through
autopsy
imagine
symptoms right symptoms can appear years
or even decades
after the last head trauma occurred and
can present and this is spooky really
memory loss severe headaches erratic
behavior and tragically
suicidal tendencies
now neil
this literally
hits home for me
i had 14 years as a pro i didn't just
head a soccer ball
i practiced heading a soccer ball oh you
did it even when you oh right because
there's a technique there's a way to do
certain things in a certain way so
this is interesting deeply for me now
our clinical expertise will come from
our good friend and neuroscientist dr
heather berlin who will join us
later in the show but
let's meet somebody um
nine years ago
this person
was diagnosed with cte
and i want us to listen to their story
and hopefully walk away from this
podcast having learnt something
and having become enlightened on a
subject that
is only in the last few years receiving
the attention it deserves so i would
like to introduce our guest
leonard marshall now if that name sounds
familiar this is a two-time super bowl
champion this is a two-time pro bowler
two-time nfl defensive lineman of the
year
that's not where it ends he's also been
a professor of sports management at
seton hall stillman school of business
he's an advocate for athletes who are
suffering from cte and he went toe to
toe with the nfl to win a class action
case to get money for other players who
aren't as affluent but are suffering all
the same he's also an entrepreneur he's
also a philanthropist
as well as a cbd advocate
neil please don't have a chat with
leonard
leonard welcome to star talk dude well
thank you very much for having me gary
what a great introduction and i
sincerely appreciate that
and some of the touching points that you
uh that you eloquently talked about
if it wasn't true i wouldn't say it nope
that's true
i would
[Laughter]
let me just catch some people up on some
on your resume here so
uh if i understand correctly
if you're in the super bowl you can't
also play in the pro bowl is that
correct
well that was before uh
uh today's football yesterday's football
you finished the season
and then two weeks after the season was
the pro bowl so you would play the super
bowl and then you would fly to hawaii
and it was kind of cool yeah and still
do that okay yeah
yeah it was kind of a gift and a curse
at the same time because your body was
so beat up in the super bowl so you were
ready for the season to be over if you
played in the super bowl anyway but most
guys look at the pro bowl just to kind
of have fun drink my ties and lay on the
beat
i mean yeah if i want a super bowl i'd
still go to hawaii i just lay on the
beach
i go to hawaii with a very sudden ankle
injury
right before the game
[Laughter]
worst case of broken eyelash ever
so leonard you got here a book title
when the cheering stops yes and oh my
gosh i mean that's a what a title of a
book that is i mean
you know
it's it's almost as though
whatever are my worst
thoughts
that's what's going to be in that book
and so
what
at what point were you motivated to say
more people have to know about what has
happened to me 2007 2009 meal
i began having issues
i felt with traumatic brain injury i
started receiving phone calls from
friends of mine around the league guys
that i played with and against
and uh and several of those guys were
they were kind of stuck
they they felt like they didn't have an
outlet
they were having
some
real problems at home
they weren't able to articulate what was
going on because they really didn't know
what was going on
all they knew is
you know when they played the game and
they were concussed in the game they
were told just what every other tough
guy is told rub a little dirt on it
you know rest a little bit and go on
back in there and do what you do
well
that just doesn't work well with 310 20
pound linemen in the national football
league when men are playing for money it
just doesn't doesn't work that way so i
didn't find out until
i'm going to say a cool 10 12 14 years
after the game
uh was over for me
because my career ended in 1996
and uh i became a dad in 1995.
so the entire time that i'm going
through this process
i'm 100 concerned about
what's going to happen to my little girl
if i'm unable to be her father
what is my wife going to do when she has
to take care of not only my child but me
too
and then
what is the league going to do to make
sure that
the quality of my life does not diminish
because
the one thing you don't get when you
leave pro football is health insurance
benefits
you get 18 months of cobra
and if you don't go into private
business or you're not smart enough to
connect yourself with a company
uh to gainfully become employed
you will have the
the biggest
problem in the world in trying to find
an insurance carrier that will
underwrite you of course after a career
in the national football league because
you're bringing baggage
is it still that way why is it still
that way it's still that way
i remember some time ago during a um
player negotiation with the owners that
that was on the table some form of
healthcare stuff and they they quashed
it like the owners they just quash it
right away this is something that they
really are adamantly against yeah you're
not you're not getting chuck you're not
getting that that that 40 acres in the
meal when you retire and you walk away
you're just not going it's not going to
happen you know
and i don't know why i don't know why
that the predecessors that continue to
be involved in professional football
they haven't taken a stronger stance on
that especially for the guys that built
the game
like myself right like the household
names of guys that you knew and know of
right in uh doing your genre of work and
everything else so it just it just
doesn't make any sense guy well by the
way you were you you were a household
name in my house because you played for
the giants
and uh i'm an eagles fan so we just
hated you right right right as long as
you want my friend's job no because he
ate he ate quarterbacks you know what i
mean he said it was my third time in in
the giants history or something like
that yes the third of all time and uh
most of those sacks were against the
philadelphia eagles so uh thanks a lot
the thing here neil is what leonard said
reminds me of a wonderful phrase and i
can't remember who is the author of this
but standing on the shoulders of giants
right of course this is isaac newton
newton
if i can see farther than others it's
because i've stood on the shoulders of
giants who have come before me and
correct giants like leonard
and and he he's respectful of those that
came before him
it's a it's a it's a heritage and a
lineage that should be carried forward
and people need to learn to look
backwards sometimes and not just
forwards but also i just want to add if
correct me if i'm wrong leonard
football careers relative to
tennis soccer baseball are notoriously
short because you can't do that
you know
late into your life
as in
30s and early 40s the way many baseball
players do so
the many football players again correct
me from wrong this is just my
understanding are not the the marquee
players that make the zillion dollars
that are household names most of them
are are service players filling out the
team and so they don't then have these
huge
financial reserves
to then
carry them out for the rest of their
lives is that an accurate
characterization yeah accurate
characterization
when i played the game from 1983 to 96
because keep in mind i went through two
strikes in the nfl
um i went to the spike in 87 i went
through the strike in 92 which granted
us free agency so
i'm one of the pillars
of
what you see now in terms of in terms of
uh compensation players are being paid
let's just put it like this for the
giants to put my team on the field that
won the super bowl in 1986
they would have to borrow money from the
jets to do it
right because there's no way you're
gonna have
two defensive players side by side like
chuck talked about lawrence taylor and
leonard marshall with over 200
quarterback sacks between them and the
middle linebacker harry carson who's
also a hall of fame linebacker on the
same defense along with george martin
and carl banks and jim burke there's
those seven guys they will never beat
seven players on the field at the same
time
on a team like that ever again they just
don't have the money to do it
they don't have the property
let me ask you a question because you
had
714 tackles during your nfl career
correct right how many times did you get
tackled how many times did you get hit
and should that actually go down now
as a stat that people recognize well i
could tell you this
if you want to talk about getting dinged
in a football game i could tell you how
many times i got this now thing to me is
when
you get hit or you have a head-to-head
collision yeah and you get up and you
don't know where you're at oh
there's got to be a worse word for that
come on leonard
it's called a life-changing event in my
life because you hanged upside the head
come
on give me a word for that yeah these
are proud tough guys
who were playing the game for money
and
the the thing is if you show softness
right guys will come after you yeah oh
they said getting your bell rung you got
your girlfriend
and i'm like what is it a liberty bell
because god
yes see the thing the thing is if if you
show the weakness not only are you lit
up for your opponents but your coach is
looking and all the coaches around him
was looking forward
to play in the next game
i had a nut job of a coach by the name
of lamar leachman
from cartersville georgia let let me
tell you something
this guy
he looked like hercule rock from the
flintstones
early afro he talked like he was black
he was he was a five foot eight five
foot nine white guy from cartersville
georgia
that that was
i i it just looked like hercules he had
these big arms little bitty legs they
would it was knocked me
and uh
it was just the funniest
i don't want to swear on him but it was
the funniest thing you had to see man
and and he'd walk around and he teased
guys he'd go oh what happened to you
there pretty you were too you were too
soft on that one oh man there it is
knocked the living i don't know what out
of him there it is oh you know you had
guys like that wow so let me i can
quantify this because i did a
calculation all right so so you were
sick you you were six four
um and how far how fast did you run a 40
4.7 seconds damn okay and and you came
in at what
i came in the nfl i weighed 290 pounds
i slimmed down i was i was at 18 body
fat i went down to almost 9 body fat wow
282 pounds and i could bench press 500
pounds and squat almost 800 pounds okay
i'm showing you
when when my my coach had a motto
when hit the body will bend or break his
deal was he wanted to see if somebody
could knock a player hit a player so
hard that he could knock him into the
middle of next 11 next tuesday
all right so here's the thing i did a
calculation all right so there's the
energy of a bullet fired from a rifle so
the ak-47 which is a high muzzle
velocity rifle we've all heard of it
used for most of the rest of the world
and
you can ask how much energy is in that
bullet and it turns out you
running into a quarterback
okay at 15 miles an hour okay not even
as fast as you can run just as fast as
might be common and you hit a
quarterback it is the same amount of
kinetic energy as a bullet fired from an
ak-47 weapon the difference is of course
all the energy of the bullet is entering
just a single hole that it puts in your
body and it rips out your organs on and
it can kill you
your energy is now spread it's the same
energy but it's spread over the entire
body of the person
so just to think about this that
that energy
would normally kill someone in one spot
but now it's spread over so the whole
body is participating and absorbing the
energy and that can't be good is what
i'm saying no next time
something you just touched on the reason
why i could hate mill from san francisco
today oh because of joe
see the thing is john montana yeah what
joe should realize is it's a good thing
that leonard is as big as he is
now so when he why don't you speak to
johnny cause he would little or he'd be
dead
he was the size of a bullet
oh i see what you did there
[Music]
that's a good one
don't worry
i'll spin him
okay so we can we gotta get somebody
very little to hit tom brady
i gotta take him
my boy hates tom brady
just cause everybody's whooping the
philly's ass all the time i mean not the
phillies what
he took our first super bowl from my
life all right yeah yeah okay took it
from you it was yours right he took it
from my life we got to take a break
leonard uh when we come back more on
this subject and we're gonna set up the
whole
uh
table so that when heather comes in uh
our neuroscientist in the third segment
um she'll put a bow on all of this and i
just want to tell everyone that heather
brought you to us you already know
heather and this is this is just just
spend it like 30 seconds how how you
found her and how you know each other i
got introduced to heather by
an organization called caring kind
which is in new york city which i'm
being honored for my work in als and
traumatic brain injury and um a young
lady by name of courtney dawson thought
it would be good for me to talk to
heather because of my life the traumatic
brain injury i'm dealing with and the
fact that cte dominates my life now and
i combat it and fight it with marijuana
and uh and cbd
and um
you know that's that's okay but the
excellent way that's the same reason i
combat my problems well that's what your
marijuana
that's that's what i tell everybody
i'm like i'm fighting man i'm fighting
problems you got your own things all
right
i'm just trying to help leonard marshall
out yeah i need him
all right when we come back more with
our super bowl nfl great uh leonard
marshall we're talking about concussions
on star talk sports edition
we're back star talk sports edition and
we've got somebody who
is an nfl great by any metric
who had sustained and persistent
dings as he called them this is a a head
hit in the nfl where you don't quite
know where you are when you get up yeah
and
uh and our man is here with us today and
it's leonard marshall again uh our for a
second segment here leonard thanks for
for uh giving us this piece of your life
and telling us um what happened to you
and how and why
by the way leonard um just to let you
know the insurance companies
actually used to allow you
to determine how bad an accident was
they would say
uh describe and anybody who caused the
accident would be like oh it's a ding
it's just a ding right and the person
who received the accident was like no
this my car is totaled right right
you know and now they say do the airbags
deploy that's how they convert it right
there it is there it is
um so uh leonard you finished your
career at what year was that uh
1996.94 was my 94 was my last active
season
my child was born in 1995 and 96 i
decided to hang it up there it is and so
uh years later five six years later you
went to ucla
for a diagnosis
of your condition
that would normally be identified
via autopsy
this is freaky that's a freaky fact yeah
was there some new way to
make the measurement or did you just
sort of force
force it in on people and say look
something's going on
invent some new test because otherwise i
don't want you to do this after i'm dead
this is great how this happened so
i got a phone call from my little
brother who happened to be teammates at
rodney hampton and notice anderson
uh and those two guys were
were like
very close to me
uh one was with me in super bowl ladies
21
and then and one was with me with two
both 25 and then the other was just with
me in tuple 25 so one i played two
championships one i played one
championship they told me about a
program that was going on an attorney
out of pittsburgh that i needed to speak
to my name is jason lucasevic from a law
firm goldberg persky and white he said
there's a program that's being
implemented by dr bennett amalu
dr amalu happened to be a
neuropathologist from allegheny county
in pennsylvania and working alongside of
jason lucasevic's brother in that
department studying brains and autopsies
of brains
long story short jason said hey leonard
espn is uh partnering with tallmark to
do this brain scan at ucla at the nancy
reagan center oh you're interested i
said well who else was involved he said
well joe de la malor hall of famer mark
duper potential hall of famer
and uh and tony dorsett hall of fame
would you be interested in going i said
count me in we take the trip to l.a we
go through the tallmark process
the process
was put in place to determine cte in the
living everyone kept saying there's no
way you could do
and
and perform cte in the living or
obtain the information
to
collectively convey gt in the living
without having these scans and without
having an autopsy of the brain these
guys proved it wrong to be well and this
group was based in chicago illinois so i
took the trip
i kicked the tires espn recorded the
whole process
and at the end of the day i came back i
had cte
see dr romalo is
the the
the centrum of the film concussion
correct yeah right that's right that's
why you know the name oh yeah yeah
leonard
please describe to us
what the doctors were looking for
and how they went about testing we said
about an mri brain scan but what else
did they piece together and come from
otherwise in an autopsy they open your
skull pull out your brain and put it
through a meat slicer they had a nice
thin slice and they look at it under the
microscope and then they say yup he had
see
so i'm just glad they didn't they had
another way
you know just dude me too i mean dude
here's what was funny neil they had the
they had a pet scan they had a cat scan
and there
they injected me with dye yeah they also
i also did a neural psych examination at
an aptitude test and from that that's
what i saw
they had to determine that you know his
skill set is not where it should be
given his age
uh the number of years he played
football and what he's going through now
so i said well fellas what did we do
with this
we came back in 2011
jason said leonard
i just got through talking to vernon
maxwell brennan maxwell is down to file
this lawsuit
uh regarding a concussion claim are you
interested in doing it i said i'll miss
doing it under one synopsis that we do
it on my daughter's birthday
so that if i forget
because of debilitation in my brain
due to tall protein on my brain and the
tall protein dominating my brain that my
daughter can remember it i want it on
her birthday
that she'll know every year
what her father stood whoa that's what i
did
leonard uh let me just say on behalf of
your daughter it's a hell of a lot of
pressure to put on me man
it stops
oh you know no i'm joking like this i'm
good eddie doesn't make it for another
seven eight nine ten years baby at least
you know there'll be something there for
you
no no i'm i'm going to understand i
think it's a great thing
it makes your daughter a part of your
legacy which is exactly what you were
doing and i think that's fantastic yeah
i mean yeah i lost reggie roby i lost
reggie roby to this i lost your eagle my
brother andre waters to this yes
okay yes
you know uh uh you know there's a couple
other guys i won't mention names because
they're dealing with it now but i can
tell you that my friend
who
you know very well
um uh your middle linebacker mr seth
joyner
uh was one of the guys that made me step
out to andre
right because i had a con conversation
with him and i told him i said seth
i'm in new york
my voice will carry some it'll carry
some weight man if i get behind this
with my teammate harry carson we'll make
enough noise that they'll list
i said you're in a little bit of a
smaller market
down in philly
you know they might not take it that
serious but go ahead man make noise
that's your teammate
you know that's your teammate so yeah
when we think of a concussion typically
we think of a
brain injury and the person doesn't know
where they are and you got to put them
under observation for 12 hours we're
actually talking about something
different here where it is the
accumulation
of smaller
brain trauma correct
and so it and what makes it particularly
pernicious
is
you just pop back from that not thinking
you really should have sat out the rest
of the game and so
and you just keep going and this
accumulates and then you get this
condition am i am i we're on the same
page you're on the same page yeah i mean
think of it this way neil now chuck
you're a big football fan and i'm quite
sure everybody else on here is my
teammate lars taylor was known for using
his helm and his head gear as a weapon
leading with your head leading with your
head so if you lead as a defensive
player with your head you make contact
that's why if you look at football today
they teach you not to leave with your
head
that's because the word and the the word
concussion has been taken out of
football we want cte to be the world
associated with football right because
we want people to accumulation of hits
cause problems down the road
right it's one thing to get concussed is
something else to have
you know have the shakes and triggers
and everything else associated with head
trauma right right
did putting a name to your condition
help and secondly when you spoke about
the build-up of the tar protein in your
brain
how did that how did the doctors bring
that forward for you to explain exactly
what the process was how it goes from
you being hit to this development
because
it seems funny that this can take so
long to to present well when when when
it was examined and
i left two people out of this that need
to be in this dr paul nussbaum
my friend in pittsburgh
and the team doctor for the for the
pittsburgh steelers
who was my classmate at lsu dr julian
bales okay and julian bells was in the
film he's portrayed that by alec baldwin
in the film concussions
um and uh and the relationship that he
had with cyril weck
who was portrayed by uh
um
god i can't think of his name on top of
my head
um
but
you know cyril weck
and julian bales determined that
this is what destroyed mike webster
okay
it destroyed a number of pittsburgh
steelers
you got to remember
that was a team that was known for
bruising people putting people in the
hospital leading with the hair gear they
were taught and trained and they played
the game at a high level like that
that's they were football and
they were the the godfathers of football
and if you were going to be
a dominant football team you had to play
their style of football in order to be
respected
and that's who we were as the new york
giants
that's who we were doing during the era
of my career
the game was a lot different dr neal
uh than it is today today
i hear guys tell me it's called they
should call it something else ball they
don't think it's too soft of a game now
you know it's not like it's not men
playing a game for money now it's little
boys playing a game with quarterbacks
with skirts on them and such and such oh
interesting yeah just to be clear
because i like getting the long view on
these things yeah um what would the
leather heads have said about
the modern football where you have all
of this equipment you know what but
before football even had leather helmets
right you go back 120 years whatever
whenever that was so i don't think it's
some if you
the the arc of the game has been to
protect your life right so however i'm
going to push back on that just a little
bit yeah um the number of injuries in
the leather head uh era of football was
actually less because the pads and the
helmets actually became a weapon
so it gave players the ability to run
faster hit harder and make higher
impacts but also because of the
equipment they were wearing to all to
also do more damage okay but but also
they they weighed 170 pounds you
you know a bunch of chuck nicest running
around i know right right right okay
gary keep going
how many how many players currently with
us
nfl players have been diagnosed with cte
and i go back to two moments in
history 2011 david dawson 2012 junior
sal
tragically
took their own lives
i'm i'm sorry fella then yeah did that
resonate for you and were those two
points in time
something that brought the football
community to a better understanding or
did it just say oh that's sad and move
on i'll tell you why well what i think
okay
david and i were david dursin and i were
really close because he was a former
bear player he joined my team in 1990 we
won a super bowl with him
as a as a backup safety player
and uh he played a pivotal role in in
the progression of our team the whole
entire seas
his wife was from baton rouge um i knew
his family because of that
um
he plays the mega sci-fi my fraternity
um i wrote an intake letter form i
became a real brother to him
and uh i introduced him into the
fraternity through chicago and a bunch
of friends in chicago
um
david had a great business he had a
great mind he was on the board border
notre dame
he was
the number two supplier breakfast meat
to mcdonald's and burger king worldwide
wow
he had a real strong head for business
and uh you know just a really good guy
the same applied for junior sale
uh and and what was what was striking
for me
was when we introduced the movie
concussions
uh out in l.a
to the world um i got a chance to sit
with uh junior sound and junior seahawks
family and his daughter um at the uh the
premiere of the uh of the film
and uh and just listen to his daughter
talk about her dad
and talk about what it meant growing up
with him in the household and everything
else and it was just sad how
she talked that you know
i will never have those moments in time
again with him
never understand
who my father really was outside of
football
uh
it will always reflect on me
that
his life was football he played in the
league what 17 18 years
it's just it just it was it really hit
me hit home for me man that's that's why
i say what i say you know uh
i have a daughter
and and someday she's going to reflect
upon what
my body of work was and i just wanted to
have the fondest memories of that you
know my father stood for something he
was a principal kind of dude
and uh he didn't let his brothers down
that's
you know i keep thinking i keep thinking
not why is any of this even a lawsuit it
should just be
yeah okay this is you know nfl is not
short of money and and of course this
affliction is many people but it's not
everyone in the nfl right it's probably
not happening to the place kickers right
so
so it's so
so
it would be a sad indictment of the nfl
if the only resolution to come of this
is only after they are sued
i mean that just looks bad it means that
it means they're reluctant resistant
i'll do it if court makes us do it but
otherwise no i mean what what are we
what what industry are we all supporting
out here look at this way dr clarkson we
70 of the national football league is
black
the players are african-american okay we
sued okay
uh there was a an award of a settlement
90 of players that retired from the nfl
are going to end up with cte
that's a fact that came from dr ann
mckee at the university at boston
university
uh and also dr robert can
so these are things that we know
there are now there's racial norming
in this case where the neuroscience have
taken
race and used race against the 70 black
players to say well you did you had a
learning disability to begin with so
you're probably dumb
now because you had that issue with your
yeah
and and it's just an articulation of you
growing your life but yet you're not
getting any smarter
well yeah
people don't realize what leonard's
talking about is if if we go back to the
aptitude test that he talked about that
he had to take so what happens is all
the players have to take these
neuropsych aptitude tests where they
have to answer a certain amount of
questions to see how proficient they are
mentally and so the nfl is saying
basically you guys are at a lower rate
coming in because you're not that smart
coming
in with so you didn't lose any real
brain function because your brain
function was already low and as a result
these players are now not uh the funds
to protect these players after they
played are no longer available to these
these players that do not do as well on
the test so that's the wonderlic test
isn't it where you know that's the one
that link is what you use when you come
into the game but and the 16 pf used to
be in the performance those three other
pictures used to be used when you were
coming into the league those declared
whether you were going to be a first
second or third round draft pick or if
you're gonna be selected at all because
you can't read that playbook and learn
it it's one thing to read it it's
nothing to comprehend it yeah so
you have players that are like that i
mean you know i've i've seen some guys
the talent outweighs their smarts on the
field and that's the kind of play you
just kind of let him go and do things
got to do
but
got the other situation that's going on
with the racial norming that you know
that they're saying that well you
weren't that smart to begin with you
badly had a c average in college and now
we're giving you this test you're
testing it at a degrade level so we
don't think that you were injured or or
anything happened to your brain we just
think you're down
right that's not cool
that's active all right linda you
mentioned two two doctors dr mckee dr
anne mckee and dr robert cantu they are
they're part of the concussion legacy
foundation that's correct right so
someone out there
is fighting the good fight
how far are they getting
with this are they progressing at all is
there some kind of way that they are
making
progress well i'm on the board of clf
okay and clf is doing everything they
can chris lewinsky does a
fantastic job fighting for players and
their families and and their kids kids
um so i can't i can't say enough good
things about clf
dr mckee and dr cantu have always been
um
the brain trust behind
what's going on with the science of the
brain
and how it affects former players in
both the nhl
the nfl and some that have been injured
in the nba and major league baseball so
you know the work that they do is is is
consequential
to
um
a high level
of
transparency to players in their family
and and we respect and appreciate that i
think that some people don't
like dr tyson was talking about they
don't respect the science and the
science doesn't lie
the science is the science
bottom line messiah says the size you're
in the right place for that leonard
you are definitely in the right place so
we're gonna we gotta
bring this segment to a close just
before we do um are you you've been very
active just as a as a proponent and as a
supporter of all these causes related to
just
people's health after you know just is
the title of your book all over again
when the cheering stops um are you up
for an award coming up
when you bring it up dr tyson i'm up on
an award from carrington um
the uh the dinner is at the the pierre
hotel in new york st pierre hotel new
york it happens on june the 6th
2022
and uh it's the als society that's
honoring me for my work in this space oh
man that's been a real proponent
congratulations thank you very much
if we gave awards we give you a reward
right now
but it wouldn't be at the pierre hotel
that place is expensive
chuck you can get call baby no we'll do
drive
that's park avenue east baby
it is
so
leonard it's been a delight to have you
a kind of sad delight i mean i'm glad
somebody's paying attention to this yes
and that
it's um
and it sounds like
all
all forces are aligned to resolve this
in some way to redress
the problems that have happened before
and to prevent them from ever happening
again and we gotta shed a little bit of
that testosterone macho on the field
it's still an entertaining game you know
yeah
uh it's still drawn the crowds and
uh
you know
to be tackled doesn't mean you have to
not get up after it okay i'm just
you can't take contact out of this sport
because if you do this is no longer nfl
football the only i get it but there are
ways to make contact where you're not a
bully
yeah yeah the only way to take it out is
to take the head out and you can't take
the head out of football
that would be weird if you just had
bodies running up and down
endless bodies
all right leonard it's been a delight
thank you for being on star talk uh
we're gonna we're gonna pivot now to
uh to heather berlin in our third
segment and we'll tell her you said hi
leonard and we're delighted that she
brought you to us uh uh godspeed uh stay
healthy and
uh give us a holler again if you've got
more to tell on this about this story i
certainly look good all right dude all
right when we come back our third
segment will be with our our
neuroscientist at large heather berlin
will sort of
figure out what's going on here and why
and where it's going to head
in the future of the sport this is star
talk see in a moment
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about concussions
and
and many concussions actually
the kind that accumulate and turn into
something really bad later in life
something that of course
football players
suffer from many have didn't even know
that this was going on and in particular
we've went through two segments with our
special guest leonard marshall former
football player with the new york giants
two-time super bowler and uh chuck was
he an offensive tackle is that but what
is his type defensive
defensive defensive tackle protecting
the uh so he's coming after guys
so he's coming after the other team's
quarterback he's a hit man that's what
he is and he was there he was very good
at it
right yes yes more than very good at him
and
him and uh
together they were
i hated him
wrecking crew oh they were so awful
so so against your team yes exactly
they made it so hard for me
for you and your eagles so
they plucked the eagles bald yes they
did a good one that was a good one so um
so we don't have particular expertise in
the neurology of this but of course we
have a friend of star talk a go-to
person our
neuroscientist at large heather berlin
heather welcome back to star talk always
a pleasure thanks for having me yeah so
he mentioned that he had a battery of
tests that in recent years enabled
medical professionals to diagnose this
accumulation of small
bits of brain damage
known as cte and i always forget what
that stands for
chronic traumatic encephalopathy
hence the abbreviation yes
and so
so my head hurts just saying that yeah i
know right right so what we had learned
was
in the day
you would never know this until the
patient was dead and then you'd do your
normal
brain slicing on the autopsy but
apparently there's some progress where
you can do this in the living patient
but um
how
how definitive can that be relative to
just say look dude give me your brain
i'll slice it open and then i'll let you
know
i mean still the gold standard if you
want to know with um a hundred percent
you know definitive is to look
postpartum it's the same thing with
alzheimer's as well you really have to
see these um
particular pattern of these plaques
these tau proteins and these tangles um
but if you kind of piece together a
bunch of different tests some mri and
there's particular patterns looking at
pet and and tau build up in particular
parts of the brain along with these
clinical tests like neurocognitive
testing you can start to get a full
picture where you can give a pretty
accurate diagnosis
of cte but it's still not a hundred
percent so you actually see the
neuropathology in the brain itself
i know chuck i know i'm chucking gary
bustin with questions gary what do you
have for her right now
the tau protein
it just
changes and develops in a certain way
doctor so
how is it changing why is it changing
from an impact but it doesn't change
normally if you have impact on on the
body a bruise appears
right but this this protein change
happens and the bruise
and the bruise heals yeah right and then
maybe decades later
so what is the process that's going on
in there
so okay part of it is um right when you
get the impact you have this kind of
neurochemical cascade that occurs
um
you have the release of certain um
you have basically what's called neural
depolarization which releases these
excitatory neurotransmitters and it kind
of shifts the balance in the brain it
changes the glucose metabolism um and
the blood flow and then that in turn can
impair the axonal function so basically
um
a lot of these these tau proteins are in
the white matter they're in the sort of
microtubules of the brain and when you
have this complex neurochemical cascade
that occurs when there's been a
traumatic injury it sets off this
process which has a distinct you know in
the course of a couple of days you can
see it a distinct sort of process but
then
it can take years for the sort of full
damage for the death of the neurons to
occur because there's sort of a buildup
if you think of it like um
you know in the arteries when you're
having a kind of build-up of plaque over
time but it does it takes a while to
actually have like a heart attack right
so if you think of in the most simplest
terms like a build-up of sort of a gunk
that was set off by this initial
neurochemical process and over time it
can lead to neuronal death
um and i think that's the easiest way to
explain it without getting tuned and the
neuronal death that when you're talking
about the death of these neurons so
basically that's
the transmission
of
you know information in the brain that's
how the brain talks to the brain right
well i mean it's mostly you know these
it's the white matter so so think about
this you have the the brain this very
soft piece of matter inside a very rough
bony um skull that has all these little
ridges and when you get this
acceleration deceleration event um the
brain kind of shakes within this piece
that's the polite way to say you got hit
in the head
exactly
the acceleration deceleration get banged
in the head exactly and sometimes they
technically we call it a coup counter
coup event but this rocking sort of back
and forth
now there's different density between
the gray matter and the white matter in
the brain so they kind of stretch and
they move at different rates so that
causes a stretching or tearing or
shearing in the white matter
when you have the kind of shaking of the
of the brain within the skull this
tearing causes this neurochemical
cascade that i that i spoke about but
that's how they communicate the white
matter where this shearing effect occurs
is tearing this pulling it affects the
communication between different brain
areas um and ultimately so that's one
aspect that can cause some of the
symptoms um and the other is that you
have eventually this um
this neurodegeneration where you get
start to have brain death which is akin
to kind of what happens in an
alzheimer's process or other
neurodegenerative
disorders
on a personal level
i headed a football or a soccer ball if
you prefer for many years and quite some
time ago
and i would have last played a
competitive game in
the mid-90s
so the question is how long will it be
before gary can no longer have this
conversation here we go right
well
so you know it it kind of
it
there's a couple of things it could set
off a process if you already have a kind
of vulnerability toward a
neurodegenerative disorder it could make
you more vulnerable so there's something
we call cognitive reserve which is
basically kind of what is your baseline
if you have a lot of different
connections in the brain you know um
that you can afford to lose a little bit
of cognitive function a little bit of
structural stability more integrity and
still kind of be okay and get by
right so
so heather we have no idea how smart
gary was before the show
yeah
we only know him
you think
we only know him in his current state
but gary you said it's not only did you
use your head during the game practice
you'd practice yeah yeah
and you have to you will learn a
technique to head a football in the most
efficient way
which is how
you're foreign you made it on the
forehead yeah made it right on the floor
and you develop muscle you met you
develop muscular muscular density here
to strengthen so as you're able so you
don't get the whiplash if the ball hits
you in the head when you connect with it
so
you develop things like you would with
muscles for running so you develop i see
so you protected your your neck
vertebrae but your brain is mush right
that's what you're saying
like listen it's not a good thing to be
bunting balls with your head but the the
thing is not everybody develops cte
right it's a percentage um keep cheering
me up doctor
oh good okay so maybe you know maybe 30
i think is some the statistic of the
people who are let's say
playing in sports that are bunting their
head or taking a lot of um hits
um and so you know i think we still
don't fully understand why certain
people develop it and others don't
certain people have multiple concussions
over time it could it could have to do
with certain vulnerabilities it could
have to do with the age at which you
started having these
small head injuries
um
and and it's kind of like covered right
now you know some people get it and it's
devastating and horrible and others are
you know asymptomatic and perfectly fine
and i think that there is an underlying
mechanism it could be related to
genetics we don't know yet um but so
there's some help for you
um gary were you wearing a mask while
you were heading the ball
heather i've read that there are no uh
pain
neurons in the brain yeah right so yeah
so you would have no idea that you were
undergoing this slow damage whereas a
tiny little pinprick anywhere on your
skin you would know i mean even in the
most obscure places yeah i mean do you
think especially in the most obscure
that is one of the most fascinating
things about the brain is so i'm i'm
fortunate enough to be involved in some
um
neurosurgery when we're doing brain
mapping so for example we want to map
out a person's getting a lesion removed
and we want to make sure we don't take
out their language area so we while
they're in in surgery we can wake them
up we can be inside there that's nice of
you that's nice of you yeah exactly want
to take out you sound like a military
operation
so how are you feeling
they are how do you live man they're
fine they're fine
yeah it's like young frank young
frankenstein
but no so we grab we piece by piece we
use electrical stimulation stimulate
each piece and have a person talk and
eventually we hit an area where they
literally just they can't talk anymore
and we know not to take out that area
but the point is that i don't have to
remove the area in a very delicate way
but um
oh my god so you're telling me there's
something as sophisticated
as neural surgery mm-hmm y'all just
poking around that's really right
electricians
electricity
electrophysiologists and finding the
electrical connection
like no electrician would start poking
your walls to figure out where the wires
are
but the amazing thing
is that the person is awake their skull
is open we're literally you know inside
their brain and they don't feel any of
it right the thing that creates all of
our pain sensations doesn't feel
anything itself when it's being touched
or stimulated or cut into that's deep
right and it can bleed and be cut into
but you don't you don't feel it but but
it's the seat of pain itself so um the
thing about it with cte and other you
know symptoms from traumatic brain
injury is that it's it's a silent
um people are suffering with it in
science because you can't see it right
you can see see so you can see it a
little bit with these hyper intensities
we call it on mri they're like little
white spots that show up over time but
really it's subjective the person is
saying i have a brain fog i can't
concentrate i can't read or they start
acting impulsively um but but you don't
feel pain itself other than headaches
isn't often often people complain of
having headache
but that's really the meninges like a
headache is not the brain itself hurting
it's actually like a migraine is this
the surrounding membrane that does have
pain sensors in it and that's where you
actually feel the headache like what
like when you get a hangover that's my
migraine i mean i wouldn't know about
that yeah
does does the brain not have a capacity
for regeneration in certain places or in
all of it
it does i mean it's it's amazingly i
mean it's it's it's very susceptible to
damage but it is amazingly able to kind
of heal in to an extent so a lot of it
is compensatory right you can if as long
as certain structures are in place if
you have damage you can maybe build
alternative routes alternative rewire
rewind brain rewires rewire but when you
start to have these neurodegenerative
processes
so much of the brain is affected across
the board it starts to atrophy you're
losing gray matter so like i said first
you get these white matter tears but
eventually that leads to death of the
cell body the gray matter
and and then you don't have the actual
structure to support the the brain
function the cognitive function anymore
so you can compensate to an extent so if
you have one area of a brain lesion that
doesn't spread right it's not a
neurodegenerative
disorder you can create these
alternative pathways to sort of
circumvent that that damaged area but
when you start having a globally damaged
there's only so much the brain can do
to compensate
so heather i just want to just to just
to establish a baseline here of all
sciences
yours is
the most
constricted by what kind of experiments
you can do
right i mean a chemist can just re-mix
the petri dish or the biologist and then
do it at a different temperature under
different acidity a different
lighting condition whatever
you can't just walk up to people in the
street can i play with your brain you're
like you can't do that so
so how far behind are you or let me
rather rather than rather than boast how
far we've come how much more
remains to be discovered okay so i mean
look there's a lot of work we can do um
i don't do this research but there are
people in the fields who are doing
animal research right and there you can
do much more um
controlled experiments in animals um
that you can't do in humans part of what
i have always done is i try to create
experiments that would be
in humans that are analogous to what
we're able to do in animals but we have
to kind of wait for the
um right subjects to emerge so let me
give you an example like one is for
example part of my phd work was i looked
at what what is the part of the orbital
prefrontal cortex what does it do and so
in animal models in mice you and and
monkeys you can lesion that part of the
brain specifically and then do
experiments you can't go in and lesion a
human so what i had to do is sort
through this was in london um
at king's college london the
neurosurgery department
sort through patient files of patients
who have come in who are still alive who
have had the particular type of brain
surgery because it was removal of a
tumor or because they had damage to that
part of the brain because of a stroke or
an aneurysm where i would find those
specific patients that happen to have
damage to that part of the brain and
then bring them in for a study but that
takes longer so the thing is we can do
these studies but the length of time it
takes to gather the patients who have
naturally gotten damage to these parts
of the brain let's say um can can um
increase the length of time it takes us
to make these discoveries so if i was to
give you a number i mean like it's very
hard to say
how much longer you know it's taking us
because we don't have control in human
studies but we are developing techniques
where we can do non-invasive stimulation
to brain parts which in effect knock
them out temporarily and that's helping
us make some advances so we're getting
more creative with the kinds of
experiments we do in humans well heather
we gotta we gotta bring this to a close
but before we do could you tell us how
you came to know about leonard
marshall's case because you brought him
to us for us to create this show yeah
yeah um i was i was i do a lot of work
with um alzheimer's patients and people
with neurodegenerative disorders and as
well of with cte and um
i was connected with him basically to
talk uh to him about his
the cognitive functioning problems that
he's having and see if there's any um
treatments and also to
help you know spread the word about this
because it's it's a major problem
that i think needs to that in in some
ways you know is not getting the kind of
coverage that i think it needs there's a
lot of people suffering with this
and um and they're doing it behind the
scenes so i he was i think we learned
offline what was it was it offline chuck
where we were talking about a helmet
brain or something or head brain what's
that with with sled sled head
yeah sled head
bob sledder is where they're you know
you can see this camera
yeah it's constantly vibrating on on the
ice so this sounds like a broader
issue with regard to sports where your
head gets dinged right i mean this is
obviously it's not just football i think
you know 100 years from now we're going
to look back on the way we've played
sports and how little we you know how
much we disregarded the damage that was
tapping to the brain and we're going to
think you know
just the way we look back to the 19 i
don't know 50s and everybody was smoking
including doctors and you know saying it
was good for you like i think we're
going to look back on this and look at
it with similar disdain
um there's a lot of money involved in
sports and a lot of people say well they
get paid millions of dollars so i guess
they're sacrificing their you know brain
as a consequence but right right right
yeah anyway i think well by that time
all sports will be played by robots
and all the kids playing video games now
will be the real athletes who are
controlling those robots
and you know and then there will be a
big movement of people who are like
saying well you know we have to care
about the robots and their brains you
know because their central processing
units are getting damaged in this sport
and why should they get there this is
chuck's chuck
sci-fi apocalyptic thriller yeah man
i do think that the way that you know we
care very much about athletes physical
bodies and they have trainers and they
take care of them and they get massages
whatever we should think about also
taking care of the brain as well and
brain health in the process that that's
a place where we haven't arrived at yet
but it is completely where we should be
headed yeah in the future we probably
will have
way less more contact in our sports
and
the sort of extreme sports that and you
might then push
what we consider mainline sports like
sledding
and push them into the extreme category
and then reduce that because of the
damage that's potentially taking place
or maybe just take heading out of soccer
as well right that's on its way that
that i can tell you
maybe in 30 years time there will not be
heading of a football and maybe in 30
years time in soccer they'll just use
their hands cause what the hell man
that's what you got him for
just dangling there doing nothing
two perfectly good utensils with
opposable thumbs and you're like nah we
can't use those what would we ever use
those for
okay chuck just blew a gasket which
means it's time to close this out
[Laughter]
gary chuck good to have you and enter it
is a delight always to have you
enlighten us in all of your neurological
ways alright this has been star talk
sports edition as always i bid you
[Music]
you